[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut tout le monde ce coup-ci vous
l'avez compris je porte ma chemise bleue
donc c'est encore un sujet alors on va
repartir de nouveau à l'époque des
années 80 l'époque des bons dessins
animés à l'époque où il y avait pas
encore Internet où on connaissait
tellement bien les programmes télé qu'on
savait exactement à quel moment passer
d'une chaîne à une autre pour se faire
des journées nonstop de dessin animés
c'était aussi l'époque où tu commençais
tes journées avec or puis après tu
passais chez Dorothé et j'arrête pas de
parler des émissions qu'il y avaient le
matin mais vous vous souvenez de ça
aussi et de
[Musique]
ça ça met un coup de vieux ben oui il y
avait aussi les émissions l'après-midi
l'après-midi tu passais sur Disney
Parade ou sur Disney dimanche et puis tu
finissais ta journée avec sa cartoon sur
Canal Plus en
clair d'ailleurs sa cartoon quand tu
entendais ce générique ben tu étais un
peu triste en fait parce que ça voulait
dire que le weekend était fini hein
c'était la dernière émission que tu
voyais le dimanche avant de préparer ton
sac pour aller à l'école le
lendemain enfin bref je vais faire mon
vieux con mais franchement tout me
paraissait excellent même les trucs que
j'allume un peu des fois genre je sais
pas le générique de DBZ au fond bah
finalement ça fait partie de mon enfant
ça fait partie de ma jeunesse finalement
je les aime bien quand même hein mais
pourtant mine de rien ben on commence à
avoir aborder un peu tous les sujets
hein parce que je vous ai finalement
parlé en fait de presque tous les type
de dessin
animé sauf un parce queil y a un type de
dessin animé dont j'ai presque jamais
parlé un type de dessin animé qui
pourtant devait bien occuper facilement
un tiers du temps d'antenne et vous
savez bien de quoi je parle puisque
c'est justement à cause de ces dessins
animés là que nous les mecs on avait
inventé des techniques ultra
sophistiquées pour les éviter justement
bah oui à force tu savais que après tel
ou tel desess animés sur TF1 fallait
zapper sur la 2 ou sur la 3 en attendant
que passe l'horrible épisode de Candy ou
de Sophie et Virginie alors bon ça
marchait pas à chaque fois quand même je
veux dire souvent tu étais obligé de te
mater l'épisode de julet je pour pas
louper le début des BZ mais ça
permettait quand même d'éviter un saqu
et paquet de trucs
chiant mais pourtant ces dessins animés
ils ont bien existé et aujourd'hui on va
en parler allez accrochez-vous les mecs
aujourd'hui on va bouffer du dessin
animé pour fille tu me transformes cette
émission entre gros et chien pour nana
s'il te plaît ok ça marche
ouais je fais des sons parce qu'on a pas
de clavier en fait ah c'est pas encore
assez ça fait pas assez fill là rajoute
plus de trucs mignons
[Musique]
ok voilà c'est rose c'est flou et c'est
dégueulasse c'est bien un dessin animé
pour fille alors déjà c'est quoi un
dessin animé pour fill techniquement
parce qu'il y en a plusieurs genres par
exemple on a les inévitables chojo type
Candy genre Gwendoline Lucile où
l'histoire se concentre autour
d'histoire d'amour terriblement pas
intéressante ensuite on avait aussi les
séries pour peties filles type Mon Petit
Poney par exemple mon d'ailleurs band
enfir regardez ce que m'avez forcé à
acheter pour faire cet épisode VI de
merde et enfin on avait les séries type
magical girly Emy Jigi Suzy Vanessa il a
tout le calendrier qui est passé enfin
bref bon de toute façon notez que toutes
les séries de magical girl ne sont pas
forcément des séries pour filles
d'ailleursir du prix lunaire
transforme-moi Moon par exemple soyez
honnête messieurs on était quand même
nombreux à regarder cette série sans
jamais l'avouer devant les pote dans la
cour de
récrée d'ailleurs je dois dire que même
si je regardais pas ces séries pourtant
j'adorais les génériques bizarrement
alors bon c'est vrai que les génériques
à l'époque étaient super prenant mais
pourtant je veux dire quand tu analyses
les paroles c'était ou bien ça voulait
absolument rien dire
[Musique]
ou bien deuxième cas de figure c'était
complètement incompréhensible mais tu
les aimais quand même savez-vousah je
sais pas par exemple tu tu prends le
générique des Miniou franchement faites
l'expérience et demandez à quelqu'un de
vous chanter le générique des Miniou
normalement voilà ce qui va se passer
nous les
[Musique]
minipous dans les mur enfant où nous
allons enfant
mais c'est vrai cette série en fait j'ai
jamais compris les paroles je les ai
compris depuis l'arrivée de l'Internet
en fait vu que sur le vrai générique
c'était complètement masqué par le
dialogue des
[Musique]
personnages et c'était pas la seule
série à faire ça prenez position une
série que tout le monde a vu alors que
bizarrement fait que 1 épisodes pourtant
sérieusement est-ce que vous avez déjà
réussi à comprendre les paroles de ce
générique entre les mecs qui parlent les
bruitages de voiture on nentend
rien quand tu ve
[Musique]
turb
l'hydroglyceur hydroglyceur en
position
jeisétais pas censé nous parler des anim
oh bon écoutez histoire de commencer
tranquillement donc on va aborder une
série dont j'avais déjà parlé brièvement
dans le prier sujet lucamour et rock
roll salut je suis ma je chur chez les
bive c'est cool comme nom mais faut pas
oublier les EU parce que sinon ça fait
bien chiv et ça c'est moins cool lui
c'est mon pote Tristan mais entre nous
on
l'appelle avant c'était une femme
maintenant c'est un homme ou l'inverse
je sais plus ensemble on écrit des
chansons d'amour sur les
[Musique]
autoroutes j'ai jamais compris en quoi
une autoroute c'était sexy pour une
fille mais tant pis
elle c'est Lucile comme tous les
personnages d'animés japonais quand elle
est stressée elle court d'une façon
dramatique bi un jour on s'est croisé
dans la rue elle est tombée je l'ai
regardé elle est retombée elle m'a giflé
j'ai aimé ça lui c'est Benjamin c'est
mon petit frère ça fait des mois qu' est
squat chez des gens pour bouffer gratos
et pour que je me tape la fille du
patron il m'a dit tu vas te marier avec
Lucile j'ai entendu tu vas la baiser la
Lucile le chat a dit
décretend tu l'as baisé lucde je me suis
dit j'ai un problème bref j'ai une vie
de merde je suis Mathias
debive mine de rien on l'oublie souvent
mais cette série c'était quand même une
série musicale et qui dit série musicale
10 chanteurs et il y avait d'excellents
chanteurs dans cette série bon alors
sans parler du look des persos qui est
ben qui est-ce qu'il est le seul moyen
d'avoir l'art plus gay que ça je pense
que ça serait de porter une robe de
marié mais c'est même au niveau de
l'interprétation que des fois Sachi dans
la série est censé avoir un concours de
rock entre les meilleurs groupes du
Japon en face il y a lui c'est Sheller
hein oui voilà c'est un Trave et c'est
censé être un des meilleurs chanteurs
écoutez sa voix suave moi fâché après
toi ma chérie mais c'est merveilleux
Marina maintenant attention écoutez
[Musique]
l'artiste lorsque tu
comprendras l'amour qui est en moi tu
sentiras monter sur tes
lèvres mais si tu voulais bien que je il
chante vraiment formidablement bien
quoi c'est quoi délire on dirait que ça
été chanté par l'acteur qui fait le
chat bon évidemment je suis bien obligé
de vous reparler de Benjamin parce que
vous savez je vous avais pas tout dit la
première fois et en fait en remattant
les épisodes je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait Benjamin c'est pas seulement
un gamin super chiant c'est surtout un
[ __ ] de futur psychopathe suffit de
voir déjà pour commencer dans l'histoire
Benjamin il a rencontré Lucile une fois
un jour de pluie donc Lucile lui offre
sa fameuse
serent à rien qu'est-ce que je vais
faire sur le CIL si elle est fâché avec
Mathias oh mais je pense à quelque
chose il y a quoi à comprendre là ça ça
fait juste une [ __ ] d'étoiles bleu
comment tu en tires des conclusions
espèce de de de malade ah mon jeu est
d'accord avec nous regarde ça veut dire
que tout finira bien W
pé
wou regarde Roméo
le feu je vais tuer Lucile et brûler son
corps mais le pire c'est que depuis le
jour où il a rencontré Lucile il va la
stalker mais dans absolument tous les
épisodes Lucil Luc j'ai couru partout
pour te
trouver Lucile je t'en prie ne pars pas
attends-moi
Lucile je veux dire la pauvre Lucile
pourra aller n'importe où dans sa ville
en plus je suppose que c'est Tokyo c'est
quand même une ville immense toujours tu
auras toujours Benjamin qui sortira de
derrière un
buisson je haie ce gamin je haie sa voix
je haie ses cheveux il est complètement
taré que quelqu'un fasse quelque chose
[Musique]
mon il l'ont eu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ainsi qu'on peut dire ils l'ont eu
ils l'ont eu c'est fait c'est Benjamin
enfin il s'en a pris une ou tu es
sérieuxamin oui oui c'est incroyable
[ __ ]
oh merci mon Dieu d'ailleurs sachez que
si vous aimez cette série
elle a énormément marché en Italie alors
imaginez vous prenez une série super
chiante genre Hélen et les garçons vous
prenez un dessin animés super chiant
genre Lucile amour et rock and roll vous
fusionnez les deux vous obtenez
ça Comè Bello stare assieme a te nel
tuobccio tanto amore c'è
la série live Lucile amour et rock and
roll mon
Dieu oh mon dieu qu'avons-nous
[Musique]
fait attends il reste pas des d animés à
regarder encore c'est quoi le prochain
je crois que c'est
Georg alors Georgy c'est l'histoire
d'une fille un peu conne qui vit en
Australie avec ses deux frères AB et
Arthur pourquoi est-ce que je dis que J
est un peu conne démonstration en
image bonjour Mon Kim comment vas-tu ah
bonjour Cie comme vous êtes mignons tous
les deux j'ai une grande nouvelle à vous
annoncer figurez-vous qu'abelle revient
demain vous
m'entendez je vous dis qu'abelle revient
demain vous vous souvenez d'abelle ah
vous ne comprenez rien demain il est
là ce sont des quias ça ne parle pas
espèce de de blonde d'ailleurs je
reviens là-dessus mais cette série elle
était quand même au top en ce qui
concerne les relations malsines et les
situations déplacées je veux dire en
dehors du fait qu'il soit frère et sœur
ENF ou presque vu que Georgie n'est pas
vraiment leur sœur ils ont juste grandi
ensemble il y a quand même un paquet de
situations dans ce dessin animé qui sont
carrément bizarres par exemple dans un
des épisodes Georgie va tomber dans
l'eau et a très très froid ton front est
glacé ça m'inquiète qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire bon alors voyons regardons cette
scène donc il y a une couverture qui
veut dire qu'il y en a probablement
d'autres il y a une cheminée ils peuvent
peut-être aussi appeler le docteur
quelle solution va-t-il choisir d'après
vous
W il y avait vraiment aucun moyen plus
efficace je te donnerai toute la chaleur
de mon corps toute la chaleur de mon
amour pour te garder en vie GEG tu fais
ça pour la réchauffer
ouaisi si je reste pour
regarder après bon concernant la série
je peux pas la juger honnêtement je veux
dire c'est tellement pas fait pour moi
mais se promène de de cliché en cliché
rien que pour ça c'est
insupportable ton père vit à Londre il
t'attend là-bas c'est lui qui m'a envoyé
te chercher que dites-vous mon père est
à Londres
oui il
s'appelle oh bon ça on sait tous qui va
crever avant de dire le nom alors
arrêtez de nous faire traîner pour rien
s vous plaît dites-moi vite le
nom ah mon Dieu est-ce que c'est
possible d'avoir un truc plus nié que
[Musique]
ça alors là on est vraiment dans les bas
fonds du dessin animé pour gamine je
veux dire bon au premier épisode en fait
j'ai eu un demi espoir quand même
puisqueil y avait des méchants qui
avaient presque l'air vraiment méchant
et avec la voix de Ik du phenniix et de
stalon en plus tu devrais quitter ce
royaume tout cela concerne pas mais bon
rapidement après c'est parti en live je
veux dire ils doivent sauver le royaume
des poneys du méchant et pour ça il
décide d'aller chercher quelqu'un sur
terre pour les aider et évidemment qui
de mieux placé pour vaincre un sorcier
démoniaque et une armée de dragon qu'une
petite fille blonde de 12 ans je vais
aider mes amis j'aurais besoin de toi
moi mais qu'est-ce que je peux faire
forte mais non je suis pas forte tu sais
te battre mais non je ne sais pas mais
repose là tu vois bien qu'elle sert à
rien non que je savais monter alors bon
qu'est-ce qu'on peut réellement dire sur
cette série B touours les mêmes
intrigues avec un méchant débile qui
essaie de s'emparer du royaume des poney
tout ça mélangé avec des chansons
pourries qui nous de B
commer on comprend même pas ce qu'elle
dit sérieux c'est pas parce que tu
parles comme ça en faisant des trucs et
des machin que ça fait une putaine
chansonon allez voyons voir le film
in the World of Darkness the word of
fairy and
Magic the biggest of the word is upon
us you are the only one who can make it
[Musique]
attends mais génial ce film Mon Petit
Poney et attends je dois être en train
de rêver voyons
ouais c'est un rêve voilà nous avons
passé en revue la moitié des dessins
demi prévu maintenant transition magical
[Musique]
girl pourquoi tu m'as pas empêché de
faire ça alors en France la plupart des
gens de mon âge ont surtout connu la
deuxème génération de magical girl c'est
celle qui a commencé avec avec Gigi puis
kmy em Magi et cet et évidemment la trè
génération qui est celle de
cellerormon alors si effectivement on
est toujours en présence d'une série
pour fille on est déjà plus au niveau
d'un Candy ou d'un Georgie je veux dire
moi par exemple ça m' arrivéit de tomber
par hasard sur un créi ou un EMI magique
et de le regarder comme ça quoi
d'ailleurs c'est dingue mais crimy et
EMI magique je l' confondis tout le
temps j'étais presque sûr que c'était la
même série en fait faut dire que la
plupart des séries de Magic ont
quasiment le même scénario vous pouvez
vérifier e moi ça j'ai fait un montage
on dirait des photocopies dans chaque
série il y aura forcément une gamine en
mini jupe qui va obtenir n'importe
quelle merde en plastique rose donné par
un petit animal chiant qui qui va
l'aider à se transformer en adolescente
en pleine puberté pour aider les gens
grâce au pouvoir de l'amour ou une
connerie du genre alors personnellement
le seul animé de Magical Girl qui avait
à mon sens un scénario pas trop abusé
c'était EMI magique ou là encore bon ça
peut aller c'est l'histoire de ma une
gamine qui veut devenir magicienne et un
jour en faisant un déménage trouve un
objet ancien qui fait apparaître une
lumière devant elle qui la traverse de
part en part
oui c'est à peu près ça et donc ma se
servira de ses pouvoirs pour devenir une
magicienne connue bon bien que je
trouvais les gens un peu cons dans ce
dessin animé quand même parce que ça
excuse-moi mais quand tu vois
ça ça c'est pas de la magie ça c'est de
la sorcellerie enfin bref j'ai bien aimé
cette série donc on peut dire qu'il n'y
a que ma qui maille
mais bon après en général faut vraiment
pas regarder de trop près le scénario de
ces séries tu prends le plus vieux dont
je me souviens personnellement c'est
Gigi alors le scénario de cette série
c'est quand même assez énorme dans le
premier épisode donc on retrouve
simplement un couple sans enfants qui
n'a absolument rien à voir avec
l'histoire et là donc tu as Gigi qui
arrive avec sa caravane depuis
l'espace mais je crois bien que c'est ma
maison oui non et donc elle rentre dans
la chambre avec ses animaux elle pose
ses meubles et puis elle s'endort dans
le lit c'est mignon la mignonne petite
squatteuse le lendemain sans explication
la mère vient la réveiller visiblement
pas choqué du tout j'ai l'impression que
cette chambre n'était pas là hier soir
ouais ni l'enfant qui a dedans et le
père lui s'en va en voyage pour aller
soigner des animaux je rappelle que 8h
avant c'était un couple sans enfants et
là on a droit au plus beau what the fuck
d toute série
confondue depuis quand j'ai une petite
fille moi
bon c'est sans importance
ok très bien c'est sans importance allez
série suivante Vanessa et la magie des
rêves hein alors on retrouve Vanessa qui
se sert de son C magique donné par une
fée et si elle habillé comme Tarzan
c'est normal c'est parce qu'elle a passé
sa jeunesse en Afrique hein et tout le
monde sait que tous les Africains sont
habillés comme ça hein je suppose qu'à
un moment il y a un scénariste qui a
écrit son magical girl en mangeant un
paquet de gâteaux [ __ ] peut-être et
qui s'est dit mais oui c'est évident
clichier raciste mais non je suis sûr
qu'ils ont pas fait exprèstoi attention
s'il vous plaît pour numéro 3 de la
compagnie savaner à
destination d'ailleurs ils ont pas de
montre non plus ils utilisent des
cadrant solaires c'est écologique cela
dit j'ai gardé le meilleur pour la fin
c'est la série qui s'appelle crimy alors
là cette série elle a été écrit pour des
petites filles et aussi par des petites
filles je crois en fait donc on retrouve
l'héroïne you qui un jour voit passer un
vaisseau auudessus de sa fenêtre et
décide de lui courir après
oui donc ça retenez-le c'est un compteur
culotte parce que cette série a un taux
d'affichage de culotte par seconde assez
exceptionnel donc en arrivant you
constate que le vaisseau est en fait un
bateau géant qui flotte dans le ciel et
que évidemment personne ne l'a vu à part
eu
[Musique]
hein donc environ deux culottes plus
tard soudain il fait nuit sans
explication et là il y a deux chats qui
parlent dans un qui a la même voix que
Benjamin histoire d'accentuer le côté
relou apparaissent devant Yuk évidemment
pas surprise ce genre de chose arrive
tous les jours et l'emmène à bord de
leur vaisseau
[Applaudissements]
spatial et là à partir de ce moment-là
même la série Lost a l'air d'avoir du
sens à côté donc you est aspiré dans un
trou noir puis attrape un chamois qui
court dans le vaisseau au milieu de fé
et de lutin nu ah ti là elle a changé de
frein après le sol se fissure et des
petits poneys s'enfuient à cause de
flammes bleu mais you réussi à attraper
une épée dans le feu et s' sert pour
affronter des têtes de poisson géantes
et un dragon noir après le dragon saigne
puis le sang se transforme en perle
rouge mais un poisson lune gigantesque
goble chamoi et Yu se retrouve en train
de flotter dans l'espace près de
l'étoile
merveilleuse donc ensuite youu et le
lutin magique ont une discussion à
propos de l'étoile merveilleuse et VI
elle vient l'essayer de l'étrangler là
d'autre chose aussi belle
attends je rêve pas en plein milieu
d'une phrase elle a essayé d'étrangler
le
[Musique]
lutin quoi B c'est sans importance oh
mon Dieu bon bref sort du vaisseau
évidemment pour conclure tout ça d'une
manière parfaitement logique le
commandant lutin magique décide pour la
remercier de quoi je sais pas de lui
offrir des pouvoirs magiques pendant un
an qui pourront la transformer en
chanteuse pourquoi enchanteuse quel
[ __ ] de rapport ça avec un vaisseau
spatial rempli de chamois qui vole sa
rien mais je crois que la seule
explication logique à tout ça c'est que
finalement ben on est au
[Musique]
Jon bref voilà pour ce fantastique
premier épisode de crimy qui se finit
donc sur un plan du vaisseau qui dérive
dans l'espace les commandes ne répent
plus qui a chié par terre c'est le chin
moi ce drag toi le commandant bon ok
mais faut pas croire qu'il y a que des
trucs tendus à base de scénario de merde
et de petite culotes au Japon mais tenez
regardez ils ont justement fait un
crossover entre les quatre principales
héroïnes de magical girl il y a Vaness
et dans C les magical doivunir contreem
[Musique]
commun alors d'après vous si on mélange
les qu univers les plus roses et les
plus mignons du Japon il se passera quoi
[Musique]
fu jaon